here we go
in three
two
one
[Music]
what do we have here yeah here i thought
we were special fellas this here's
bagman hang man whatever what the hell
kind of mission is this
[Music]
everyone here is the best there is
who the hell are they gonna get to teach
us
captain pete maverick mitchell
let me be perfectly blunt
you are not my first choice you were
here at the request of admiral kazansky
aka iceman he seems to think that you
have something left to offer the navy
what that is i can't imagine
all due respect sir i'm not a teacher
i just want to manage expectations
good morning aviators
this is your captain speaking
and we're off
here we go
in three
two
one
we're going into combat on a level no
living pilot's ever seen
not even him
you think up there you're dead believe
me
my dad believed in you
i'm not gonna make the same mistake
[Music]
someone's not coming back from this
those are your pilots
anything happens to them
you will never forgive yourself
no turning back now come on
[Music]
having any fun yet
[Music]
we are cleared into the area verified
cameras are on all right here we go
three
two one
here comes some g's
there's five g's
all right
that was awesome
i wasn't ready to make a sequel until we
had a special story
worthy of a sequel and until technology
evolved so we could delve deeper into
the experience of a fighter pilot
the first movie became something that
changed a generation
so this is exciting to come back and get
in those jets again
we worked with the navy and the top gun
school to formulate how to shoot it
practically because if we're going to do
it we're going to fly in the f-18s
the aviation sequences had to be real
so our actors went through three months
of ruling training
the navy says if you eject you have to
be able to survive in the water so we
had to go through that challenging
underwater program
it's intense you're flipped inverted and
you're having to try and get out
from there tom designed this
all-encompassing aviation training for
all the actors
i started them out in a single engine
airplane
to build up their spatial awareness
inside the aircraft
we took them to the l-39 and they went
and flew aerobatics to feel what it's
like in a jet
speed wow from there they'd graduate to
the f-18 super hornet and actually
launching off an aircraft carrier
the actors also had to learn how to run
the cameras because when they're up in
the jet they have to direct themselves
essentially okay i had to really teach
them cinematography and the lighting so
that they understood what's going to
look good on camera
was great everybody thought it would be
impossible for actors to really be in
the jets
but that's the gift that tom gave us
that by the time we got up there
we could handle it
definitely the most amazing thing i've
ever done all the training 100 prepared
i'm very proud of what we all
accomplished
each one of them are extraordinary
it still blows my mind that we've done
this
there's nothing like it
[Music]
what kind of mission is this everyone
here is the best there is who's going to
teach us
they will start with what you only think
you know nice
what the hell easy maverick let's try
not to get fired on the first day
we're going into combat on a level never
seen
you think up there you're dead believe
me
my dad believed in you i'm not gonna
make the same mistake
oh my god here we go
top gun maverick pg-13
all right three two one
after 34 years tom cruise returns his
maverick
this is a competition film about family
friendship and sacrifice
it's a love letter to aviation
we're going to show you what it's really
like to be a top gun pilot
you just can't create this kind of
experience unless you shoot it live
in order for us to accomplish this we
have the greatest fighter pilots in the
world working with us
we're working with a brand new camera
system that allows us to put six imax
quality cameras inside the cockpit with
the actors verifying cameras are on okay
there you go
it's amazing what we see in the cockpit
what an audience is going to experience
thanks to tom all the actors becoming
accustomed to the g-forces by all the
training that they're doing here it is
aggressive you can't act that the
distortion the face they're pulling
seven and a half eight g's that's 1600
pounds of force i am so proud of them
and what they've done and it is heavy
duty
putting us up in these jets it's very
serious that's why everybody thought it
would be impossible and i think when tom
hears that something's impossible or it
can't be done that's when he gets to
work
flying one of these fighter jets is an
absolute thrill ride we want to make
sure that the audience has the same
experience
aviation film like this has never been
done and chancellor will never be done
again
here we go
in three
two
one
[Music]
what do we have here yeah here i thought
we were special fellas this here's
bagman hang man whatever what the hell
kind of mission is this
[Music]
everyone here is the best there is who
the hell are they gonna get to teach us
captain pete maverick mitchell
let me be perfectly blunt
you are not my first choice you were
here at the request of admiral kazansky
aka iceman he seems to think that you
have something left to offer the navy
what that is i can't imagine
all due respect sir i'm not a teacher
just want to manage
good expectations aviators
this is your captain speaking
and we're off
here we go
in three
two
we're going into combat on a level no
living pilot's ever seen
not even him
you think up there you're dead believe
me
my dad believed in you
i'm not gonna make the same mistake
[Music]
someone's not coming back from this
those are your pilots
anything happens to them
you will never forgive yourself
no turning back now come on
[Music]
having any fun yet
[Music]
you